le 17 novembre dernier dans cette zone
entre saint vincent et sainte lucie
trois hommes âgés de 28 à 41 ans 3,5
lucien naviguant dans cette union sont
prises en chasse par les militaires de
la marine nationale en panique et par
lens par dessus bord plusieurs balles ou
l'arrestation des zones est donc
privilégiée au détriment de ces ballots
qui ne seront plus localisés
dès la première audition est encore
aujourd'hui à la barre du tribunal
correctionnel de fort-de-france
les trois prévenus avance pour leur
défense qu'il pêchait simplement dans la
zone qui ont indiqué qu'ils étaient
partis pour pêcher mais qui n'a pas été
retrouvée le moindre engins de pêche à
bord de ce navire dans la mesure enfin
ou un chien dressé pour la détection de
produits stupéfiants a marqué c'est à
dire à lui démontrer qu'il y avait eu
bien présence récente de produits
stupéfiants à bord de sept viols il a
été décidé d'exercer des poursuites à
l'encontre de ces trois individus dont
l'un avait déjà été condamné par le
passé à cinq ans d'emprisonnement
ici toujours à fort de france et
toujours également pour des faits de
transport de produits stupéfiants grèce
éléments probants qui ont donc que
motivé cette décision des magistrats
malgré les nombreuses investigations les
enquêteurs ne pourront remonter à la
piste du destinataire de la marchandise
illicite
une opération menée en étroite
collaboration par la marine nationale
l'osce et retisse le parquet de
fort-de-france et le préfet au titre de
délégué du gouvernement dans le cadre de
l'action de l'état en mer